mascarillas cubriendo el rostro una
imagen que ya se ha convertido en usual
sin embargo pronto será parte del pasado
en texas para los propietarios de las
pequeñas empresas como sigue grüber es
una buena noticia
fue maravilloso de escuchar ya sabes que
nos van a dejar abrir al 100% estoy un
poco nervioso por lo que mencionaron del
levantamiento total de las mascarillas
es la mayor reversión de las
restricciones contra el coronavirus en
cualquier estado de eeuu el gobernador
greg abbott dijo que pondría fin al uso
obligatorio de tapabocas desde el 10 de
marzo entonces las autoridades no podrán
sancionar a las personas por no usarlo y
las empresas podrán reabrir a plena
capacidad durante casi medio año en la
mayoría de las empresas han estado
abierta al 75 o al 50 por ciento
demasiados propietarios de pequeñas
empresas han tenido dificultades para
pagar sus facturas esto debe terminar
la medida rompe completamente con los
lineamientos del gobierno de joe biden
quien sigue llamando al uso de
mascarillas como una de las principales
medidas contra el virus el gobierno
avanza a contrarreloj para vacunar a la
ciudadanía y prometió inmunizar a todos
los adultos del país para finales de
mayo en texas ya casi 6 millones de los
29 millones de residentes del estado han
recibido al menos una inyección pero a
pesar de ello los expertos aseguran que
es muy pronto para levantar medidas y
advierten que el fin de las
restricciones para perder el terreno
ganado en la contención de la pandemia
en el país